we saw several videos ago that we can
parameterize a taurus or a doughnut
shape as
a
as a vector position vector valued
function of two parameters and this is
the outcome that we had i think i did it
over several videos because it was a bit
hairy and i'll write i'll write our
vector position vector valued function
first so we have r as a function of our
two parameters s and t and then i'll
review a little bit of what all the
terms what the s the t and the a's and
the b's represent but it's equal to
b plus
a
cosine
of s and once again we saw this we saw
this several videos ago so you might
want to watch the videos on on
parameterizing
surfaces with two parameters to get to
figure out how we got here times the
sine of t i'm going to put the s terms
and the t terms in different colors
times our i unit vector i'll put the
vectors or the unit vectors in this
orange color
plus doing the same yellow
plus
b plus a cosine
a cosine of s
times cosine of t
times cosine of t times the j unit
vector the unit vector in the
y direction
plus
plus
a sine of s a sine of s
times the k unit vector or the unit
vector in
the z direction and in order to generate
the taurus or the donut shape this is
true
for our parameters so we don't wrap
multiple times around the torus for s
being between
this is for s being between
0 and 2 pi
and for t being between 0
and 2 pi and just as a bit of review
where all of this came from and i'm
going to have to do what my plan is for
this video over several videos but let's
review
where all of this came from let me draw
a donut
my best effort at a doughnut right here
that looks like a donut or a taurus
and
you can imagine a taurus or this donut
shape is kind of the product of two
circles you have this circle that's kind
of the cross section of the donut at any
point you could take it there you could
take it over there and then you have the
circle that kind of wraps around all of
these other circles or these other
circles wrap around it and so
we when we drove or derived this formula
up here or this per parameterization
a was the radius of these
cross-sectional circles
that's a that's what these a terms were
and b was the distance from the center
of our torus
b was the distance from the center of
our torus out to the center of these
cross sections
so this was b so you can imagine that b
is kind of the radius of the big circle
up to the midpoint of the i guess cross
section and a is the radius of the cross
sectional
circles
and when we parameterized it s the
parameter s was essentially telling us
how far s was telling us how far are we
or where how are we wrapping around this
circle so it's an angle from 0 to 2 pi
to say where we are on that circle and t
tells us how much we've rotated around
the larger circle
so t was telling us how much we rotated
around the larger circle so if you think
about it you can specify any point on
this donut or on this surface or on this
torus by telling you an s or a t and so
that's why we picked that as the
parameterization
now the whole reason why i'm even
revisiting this stuff that we saw
several videos ago is we're going to
actually use it to compute an actual
surface integral and the surface
integral we're going to compute will
tell us the surface area of this torus
so
let's this surface right here is
sigma
right like that it's being represented
by this position vector valued function
that is a parameter that is
parameterized by these two parameters
right there and if we wanted to figure
out the surface area if we just kind of
set it as a surface integral we saw in i
think the last video or at least the
last vector calculus video i did that
this is a surface integral over the
surface here this capital sigma does not
represent some it represents a surface
of a bunch of the little d sigmas a
bunch of the little chunks of the
surface and just as a review you can
imagine a d each d sigma is a little
patch of the surface right there
that is a d sigma and we're taking where
it's a double integral here because we
want to add up all the d sigmas in two
directions you can imagine one kind of
rotating this way around the torus and
then the other direction is going in the
other direction around the torus so
that's why it's a double integral
and this is just going to give you the
surface area which is the whole point of
this video and probably the next one or
two videos but if you wanted to also
multiply these sigmas times some other
values you know there's some scalar
field that this is in that you cared
about you could put that other value
right there but here we're just
multiplying it by one and we saw in the
last video that this is you know it's a
way of expressing an idea but you really
can't do much computation with this but
a way that you can express this in a so
that you can actually take the integral
you say this is the same thing and we
saw this in the last several videos this
is the same thing as the double integral
over the region over which our
parameters are defined so it's this
region over here where s and t go from 0
to 2 pi
of whatever function this is we just
have a 1 here so we don't have to we
could just write a 1 if we like it
doesn't change much
times
and this is what we learned
times the magnitude of the partial
derivative of r
with respect to s
the magnitude of that crossed with the
partial derivative of r
with respect to t
d s
you could take it in either order but d
s
d t so we saw this in the last minute
what we're going to do now is actually
compute this that's the whole point of
this video we're going to take the cross
product of these two vectors so let's
figure out these vectors in the next
video we're going to take the cross
product and in the video after that
we'll actually evaluate this double
integral you're going to see it's a
pretty hairy problem and this is
probably the reason that very few people
ever see an actual surface integral get
computed but let's let's do it anyway
so the partial derivative the partial
derivative of r with respect to s so
this term right here we'll do the cross
product in the next video this term is
what we just want to hold t constant to
take the partial with respect to just s
so this up here that if we distribute it
the sine of t times b that's just going
to be a constant in terms of s so we can
ignore that then you have sine of t
times this over here so sine of t and a
is a constant and you take the
derivative of cosine of s that's
negative sine of s so it's going to be
so the derivative of this with respect
to s so the partial with respect to s is
going to be
minus
a
i'll write in green the sine of t so you
know that's where it came from sine
of t
and then sine of s right that's the the
derivative of this is negative sine of s
that's where that negative came from and
then i'll write the sine of s right
there
sine
of s
times the unit vector
i that's the partial of just this x term
with respect to s
and then we'll do the same thing with
the y term
or the j term so plus same logic b times
cosine of t with respect to s we take
the partial just to just become 0. so
you're left with a
a well it's going to be a minus a again
right because when you take the
derivative of the cosine of s it's going
to be negative sine of s so you have a
let me do it so you're going to have a
minus a
this cosine of t
minus a cosine of t that's the constant
terms sine of s
sine of s just taking partial
derivatives
sine of s
j sine of sj and then finally we take
the derivative of this with respect to s
and that's pretty straightforward it's
just going to be a cosine of s
so plus
plus a
cosine
a cosine of s
k
and hopefully you didn't find this
confusing the negative signs because the
derivative of cosines aren't negative
signs so negative sine of s so that's
where it's negative sine of s times the
constants negative sine of s times the
constants the constant cosine of t sine
of t so hopefully this makes some sense
this is a review of taking a partial
derivative now let's say do the same
thing with respect to t
let's do the same thing with respect to
t and i'll do that in a different color
so now we want to take the partial of r
with respect to t
so the partial of r with respect to t is
equal to
so now this whole term over here is a
constant and so it's going to be that
whole term times the derivative of this
with respect to t which is just cosine
of t so it's going to be
it's going to be
b plus a
cosine of s times
cosine of t
cosine of t
i
and then plus and it's actually going to
be a minus can you take the derivative
of this with respect to t it's going to
be minus sine of t so let me put them
it's going to be
negative and then let me leave some
space for this term right here negative
sine
of t and you're going to have this
constant out there right that's a
constant in t
v
plus a cosine of s that's just that term
right there derivative of cosine t is
negative sine of t
times
j
times j and then the partial of this
with respect to t this is just a
constant in t so the partial is going to
be zero so i'll write plus zero k
plus zero
let me do all my vectors in that same
color
plus zero
times the unit vector k so that gives us
our partial derivatives now we have to
take the cross product then find the
magnitude of the cross product and then
evaluate this double integral and i'll
do that in the next couple of videos